-Jenna, you are up.
-Go get him. Go get him.
-Hold the mic.
-That was good.
-Let's see what game you get.
-Oh, Lord.
-You got it. You got it.
Come on. What do ya got?
♪♪
"Baby Got Backup!"
♪ Baby got... ♪
♪♪
♪ Baby got.... ♪
♪ B-B-Baby got... ♪
♪ Backup ♪
-All right, here's the deal.
Lady Gaga was supposed
to be here tonight.
It was gonna be a big
performance with costumes,
backup dancers,
props, everything.
Unfortunately, she had
a "thing" and she can't make it.
So you're filling in
for her, okay?
-You got it.
-You have to do
your best to lip sync
and keep up
with the choreography
and everything that
she had planned for tonight.
Let's see which
one of her songs
you'll be performing tonight.
-You got this. You got this!
-Okay.
-Come on.
-All right.
-Oh, my gosh.
This is gonna be awesome.
-Oh. Yes!
-"Bad Romance."
All right, Jenna.
-You can do it.
-Okay. Okay.
-I have a..
-Help me put this on?
-You are Gaga.
-This is Gaga's
-Ohh, channeling Gaga.
-Channeling Gaga.
This is terrifying.
-Put your hair over.
-What is that?
-Pull the hair over.
How do I do this
with your hair?
-Hey.
-Maybe I'll get your hair.
-Oh, my God.
-Hey, they got extra, Jimmy.
Come on. man.
-Is it full -- Is it a prom?
-Oh, my gosh, a prom.
Oh, my God.
-Oh, my God.
-What's happening?
-I've never been to prom.
-All right, all right.
Go take your mark.
-Kind of my dream.
-Good luck.
-Okay.
-Let's go, Jenna!
-Thank you.
-This is what Gaga
was going to do.
-Go Jenna!
-Oh, my God.
All right. Good luck.
-What's happening?
-And do not let us down.
-This is amazing.
-When did Lady Gaga go to prom?
-Ladies and gentlemen,
Lady Gaga!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Rah, rah-ah-ah-ah ♪
♪ Roma, roma-ma ♪
♪ Gaga, ooh-la-la ♪
♪ Want your bad romance ♪
♪ I want your ugly,
I want your disease ♪
♪ I want your everything
as long as it's free ♪
♪ I want your love. ♪
♪ Love, love, love ♪
♪ I want your love ♪
-Yes! Yeah!
♪♪
♪ I want your drama,
the touch of your hair ♪
♪ I want your leather-studded
kiss in the sand ♪
♪ I want your love ♪
-She's killing it.
♪ Love, love, love ♪
♪ I want your love ♪
♪♪
♪ You know that I want you ♪
♪ And you know that I need you ♪
-She's so good.
-I love her. She's awesome.
-Right?
♪ Bad romance ♪
♪ I want your love,
and I want your revenge ♪
♪ You and me could write
a bad romance ♪
-She's so good!
♪ I want your love and
all your lover's revenge ♪
♪ You and me could write
a bad romance ♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh-oh-oh,
oh-oh-oh-oh ♪
♪ Caught in a bad romance ♪
-How does she do that?
♪ Oh-oh-oh-oh-oh,
oh-oh-oh-oh ♪
♪ Caught in a bad romance ♪
♪♪
♪ Rah, rah-ah-ah-ah ♪
♪ Roma, roma-ma ♪
♪ Gaga, ooh-la-la ♪
♪ Want your bad romance ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Oh, my goodness!
You are a superstar.
That was unbelievable.